quindi ragazzi siccome settimana scorsa
sono andato a parigi non vi ho ancora
fatto vedere nulla del blog di parigi
direi che possiamo iniziare preparatevi
perché è stato un viaggio epocale ma non
avete idea di cosa state per vedere la
televisione ci siamo arrivati
non cercavo di suitex top
variazione sorti della sottigliezza
ripese il sistema infatti a parigi i
ragazzi siamo atterrati adesso deve
arrivare il tipo di ubisoft a prenderci
ci porta a fare le cose belle signore
signori ciò il tamarro grosso la
macchina siamo arrivati con la macchina
grossa dell'albergo l'albergo non
finisce dalla enorme e un hotel della
madonna ma fighissimo parte lui e poi
c'è questo ma gag
io vado che devo fare il salto inaugura
torio della storia allora già che non si
apre e partiamo da dio
minchia dello studio è bellissimo è
allora niente inaugurazione sul letto
equa e non la saltano ragazzi non
possono sbagliare così avanti ma io devo
inaugurare camera tua scusa vogliono
ancora la camera mia non essendo emersi
con ferdi che mi vuoi fare queste cose
fare le più se non mi scrivesse anche
gesù nel mentre che salto dalla ragazzi
io è da ieri sera che non cago quindi se
permettete non saltino al bagno lo
faccio ci vediamo dopo ok mentre cagava
mi son dimenticato che effettivamente
lorenzo non aveva la chiave quindi l'ho
fatto stare fuori un ora e va bene
ecco infatti dell'istat sono qui sono
qui sono arrivato sono arrivato non
arrivava almeno minica è scusami me la
sto facendo addosso mi sapete comunque
qual è il segreto
pero per essere youtubers mentre mentre
l'uomo incappucciato nero
contu parla francese
io vado nel suo bagno e ogni volta lo
faccio non ho mai legato ma lo faccio
sempre mi foto il profumo io non porta
mai a profondo in vacanza perché c'è
sempre lui e puntualmente di foto zona
sempre
[Musica]
ora gae l'albero di minecraft come fatto
a cubi se fai così il legno diventa esce
fuori poi fa il legno e le cose e
scaviamo per trovare le diamante dove
cazzo e lorenzo ho perso subito a nola
si mimetizza il vostro cappello
incredibile che mi metti mimetizzi
questo cappello nella sala sarà la mia
figlia di un tablet joojoo e si anch'io
di giovedì
siamo alle barchette io volevo essa si
con una madame marie chauvet di
disgrazie se la via nov abbiamo
veramente anche storia
lorenzo in terris tv esclusa ma che
storia o se vuoi sbattere insomma niente
sarà la stampa bari dobbiamo farlo con
la torre ecco queste cose le vedo sempre
su facebook e le fanno le coppiette
perché ci sei tu perché non era un paese
amico ma giura però polaroid se vuoi
farci il bonifico grazie sono le saline
a stampa dj set gioiese riverserà
pavilion e spagnoli
cosa stai vivendo non ne ho la più
pallida idea
va bene signori stamattina era in spagna
torna in italia gli fa gli auguri di
compleanno
e vi e prende un volo per parigi il
signore e signori nulla su realpower
bella nome fallita stamattina era in
spagna fa su spagna italia pomeriggio
registrato dei video dopo il pomeriggio
ha preso una era venuta a parigi per
farmi gli auguri di compleanno ragazzi
guarda su rimarrà come si festeggia
wow
ma se le armi nelle cure
[Musica]
ma che guai
quando
[Musica]
si no
e bravo compleanno a parigi non troppe
le zone mezzo
penso da suino marcio ed è piccola ma
lavora volare oggi a strasburgo
[Musica]
stiamo andando all'evento di just dance
devo parlare con the youtuber che sono
molto più grossi di merito va là che ci
sono i punk e aspetta siamo in francia
non ci caga nessuno vado di sala
divertente perché dovrò far ballare
davanti su un palco davanti ad un sacco
di persone
di fatto è che se sono in italia sanno
che sono famiglie che quindi sono un
deficiente che in francia nessuno mi
caga ballerino scarso di arrivare a
richiesta del pc macché maghi maghetti
porca vacca raga ma quanta gente certo
mi chiama incredibile è un games week
più grosso
[Musica]
questa bambina con la maglia rosa è alta
molti più iscritti di favi geni ed è
molto più ricca di fa vj perché fa clic
bait da molti più anni di favi j
nonostante serata dopo di fa vigenti
[Musica]
alleluia e garage
c'è chi dice che manca una faccia
bellissima io stavo così bene la mia
casa a milano a giocare non fare nulla
dalla mattina alla sera alla cena
scontro e la bambina
chi me l'ha fatto pasta pensando
posso credere
[Musica]
a vederli
voglio però uniteli e di aprire stesso
fondo cioè senza i live distanza ma
quindi seguito da lorenzo facci vedere
il tuo sguardo seducente per conquistare
le ragazze era servito
bello e quante cross stop at the ark
oddio enorme questo semaforo perché se
esiste forse una foto sul semaforo quale
che problemi al cervello a questa
persona ma che sofficini in mano non ha
segni il mio culo sopra le sottilette
big bubble sto fumando sofficini sto
mangiandosi un cani tenero paura che me
ne fotte di storia power c'è un cane
stiamo facendo le cose cuciniamo come
carlo cracco io che io che so cucinare
lo sapete tutti ho preparato questo per
i ragazzi ho preparato questo che se lo
possono cuocere piace come ho preparato
la tav
io gli ho preparato la tavola e adesso
sono io che sto girando con la mia mano
mentre sto bloggando festa la mia mano
vuoi fermarti weiner dall'altro lato
dove ci sono giardini
ok allora riprendi la vacua dal
finestrino ma che ci faccia importava
deal ragioni giardino
va bene raga dopo una vita ci siamo
siamo arrivati anche qua siamo arrivati
sotto la torre eiffel e mi mancava sta
roba mancava ha poca roba era da un po
anche alle piramidi e poi ho visto tutto
ciò è veramente finita è arrivato il
ponte del sole virani non pensavo fosse
così grossa e proprio grossa
siamo sulla tour eiffel porca eva si
vola martin garris animal sotto altro è
bello che c'è il faro che parte
nettamente la torre che mi senta milan
ci starebbe tutto noi a torino abbiamo
la mole antonelliana e muti francesi
fuggiti adesso siamo arrivati in questo
posto che prettamente turistico dove le
persone sono solite a mettersi sui cosi
per poi fare la foto con con il
monumento alle spalle con la torre di
pisa sempre voluto farlo lo fa anche
salvo e dopo lo faccio anche io c'è un
po di sole non vedo bene ok no e se vuoi
fare la positiva abbassarti un po ok
huanan calatina anche un po alla schiena
ok ora mette mai in avanti non solo una
solo una ok è troppo la mano destra un
po più bassa
un po di più ok per assalta tre volte
complimenti puoi andare a narnia ok
perfetto
la foto gli è venuta da dio sicuro
qualcuno abbandonato ma gag facciamo una
foto romantica ci sono gli alberi di
minecraft della tua i fell quindi
qualche ci rimaniamo stai qua porto il
demonio basta ma [ __ ] mi son
cagati si registrano si sa infatti non
capivo dove i ragazzi questo è il blog
di parigi è stato assurdo veramente
saponi più dei viaggi della mia vita
perché è stato tutto improvvisato ballo
sul palco a parte la creazione come da
tradizione si sente così rischiate che
ci vediamo possono evitarlo se mi
chiedete perché c'è una scala e perché
[Musica]